that is the bitcoin
rabbit hole in a nutshell is it you know
they say fix the money fix the world you
keep tracing these different
um social malaises or or you know
technological
difficulties lack of innovation you know
weinstein's entire
portal podcast something went wrong in
the early 70s
we went off the gold standard in 1971.
and there's a great website
wtfhappen1971.com goes to this whole
gamut of socioeconomic data that's
completely gone uh askew since like
since the early 70s yeah you had this
whole video what do you think about eric
weinstein and uh
and bitcoin and the gold standard and
does he i actually haven't heard him
talk about his uh
thesis about the the 70s in connection
to the
going off of the gold standard um yeah
what are your thoughts there
what what are your thoughts about his
general relationship with the
with the bitcoin idea and the community
yeah the first exposure i had to eric
was his
i think was his first episode with peter
thiel and they're going through that
thesis that there's been this
general institutional rot and
suppression of innovation since the
early 70s and he's
trying to identify what it is i don't
think they ever penned it on the money
on going off the gold standard but in
recent
um interactions with eric you know i've
interacted with him on clubhouse
um we recently released an episode of
the show
i did with chris espley and it was
titled dear eric weinstein so we're
going through
his world view that he's expressed in
the portal and tying it back to
the money in in different ways and he's
been he's engaged
eric uh retweeted the show we have
exchanged some messages he's been very
open-minded
he's asked some really good questions so
i get the sense that he's approaching
this
um very wholeheartedly uh he does bring
with him his existing worldview and his
existing theory the one that really blew
up was gage theory they got really
popular
i don't know a lot about gage theory i
actually messaged eric and said i want
to learn more genuinely because
um you know he seems to be serious that
that
needs to be considered in the sphere of
money and so i want to learn more about
it
um but i think overall it's great it's
great to see
an intellectual heavyweight of his
caliber gravitating towards bitcoin
yeah he has some gauge theoretic
conceptions about the world broadly
but also about economics
which ultimately boils down to just a
set of mathematics
which allows you to more effectively
reason about the world and he has
a certain set of views there so
it's fascinating to see him grapple with
it i think he's also kind of
actually kind of like all of us uh
grappling with the idea of what is
bitcoin
in this world it's a very young
technology and
it's unclear exactly how the ideas of
the past
fit with it yeah and integrate how the
two integrate together and so
it's interesting to explore uh not just
bitcoin the particular so for me
like what i always uh saw bitcoin as
from the beginning from a narrow
world view is computer science which is
what
where i come from and so i wasn't almost
aware
in the uh social political financial
aspects of bitcoin
but now i see that there's
not just power but there's fascinating
ideas to explore
on that side of things not just the
computer science not just the technical
details
but the political the socio-economic
yeah
the philosophical yeah yeah that's where
i you know
find all the fascination in the world
frankly um
i would i would one other thing about uh
weinstein and intellectuals
more generally that are skeptical of
bitcoin i would challenge them to read
the book
human action written but written by
mises
i think in 1949 he published the english
version uh it's essential essentially
the the bible of austrian economics
and i think austrian economics is a
noticeable gap
in most modern intellectuals world views
that it's not taught in school i mean i
have a master's degree in accounting and
finance
you know studied a lot of economics in
school there's not one peep of austrian
acon
the the oh yes talking about all the
degrees he has
i was a cpa
but it's it that curriculum that we get
in college is noticeably deficient in
austrian economics
and i think there's a reason why right
it's it's heavily government influenced
um again master's degree in accounting
they never
taught me about what money is or where
money comes from all you learn is that
the central bank issues money and the
central bank takes money away
so it's it's conceived of in the
textbooks quite literally as god
right an entity that suffers no
opportunity cost
that um basically is the foundation of
the entire
keynesian worldview that you're taught
in economics
and austrian economics is the
opposite end of the spectrum of that
right it's it's actually the culmination
which economics is the youngest science
in the world by the way
so it is kind of the front
it's the frontiers of science in many
ways like to actually
when i say praxeology many people have
never even heard of that
but it's something uh it's an a priori
study equivalent to something like
mathematics that you're building things
from first principles
to reason about economic reality and
i think that book it's a very difficult
book written by mises 1200 pages
translated from german the way he wields
english is fascinating and terrifying
all at the same time
uh it probably takes you six months to
read it if you read it daily seriously
like it's a
it's a beast of a book but that will
plug the gap
i think in most any intellectual that's
skeptical about bitcoin i think that
will plug the gap
that's necessary for you to see it in a
new light
well i'll take that as a challenge
you